in Daniel Defoe's famous novel Robinson
Crusoe we read of swashbuckling stories
of adventures on the high seas we read
of trials mishaps misadventures Robinson
Crusoe enact some curious habits upon
himself every night as he goes to bed he
sleeps on the beach he points his toes
towards the ocean every morning the tide
rolls in wets his feet he rises it wakes
him up now while the tide may not be
exactly regular in this way Robinson
Crusoe orders his life through habits he
sets rules for himself but let's not
just a listen to this story let us ask
why Robinson Crusoe is in the state of
nature isolated he has no social
responsibility and answers to no man but
himself but he understands the crucial
lesson that rules help us better govern
our lives and help us to live more
ordered and more fulfilling lives when
we come together in society especially
political society we enact certain rules
with how we interact with one another
how we treat one another and we set
limits on how those rules can be enacted
to begin with however in 21st century
America we have fundamentally changed
what the limits are on the rules that
are created for how we govern ourselves
and this leads us to a point where
ultimately we live under a different
contract than that under which we first
agreed to coexist as a society so let us
ask of ourselves as we asked of Robinson
Crusoe why to answer this question we
must examine three things first why do
we make these rules in the first place
secondly what are these rules and what
are their limits and finally how have
they changed if at all before we can
truly understand the impact that this
has on our everyday lives James Buchanan
a Nobel Prize winning economist argues
in his works reasons of rules and limits
of Liberty that mankind comes together
not as Locke says to defend our rights
in society but to enact an external
enforcement agency for the rules with
how we treat one another
now while these two philosophies may
have the same end we see that there are
two different types of rules under
buchanans line of reasoning there are
the rules by which we engage with one
another so I notice dr. Ahrens tie for
instance may not be quite as shiny or
quite as bright as mine but he can't
just take mine I get to protect it those
are the rules under which we live I
apologize dr. I'm but those are the
rules but there's another set of rules a
set of rules that govern how we can
create those rules to begin with and
this is the constitutional side of the
rules this set of rules governs the
government of the United States of
America in the form of the United States
Constitution Buchanan calls this the
paradox of governance every night with
good intentions I set an alarm clock
before I go to bed and every morning I
curse that decision as i hit snooze at
one time i know that that is a good rule
for my life but there's a temporal
disconnect between that knowledge and
the actual action that results from it
wherein I may disagree with that rule
that I set up for myself now let's not
take this to the extreme to say that
once we enter government there may be
things that happen that we disagree with
them we have no recourse however the
paradox of governance shows us that it
is for this reason that we make rules in
the first place because we know that
eventually we won't agree with them but
if this is why we have these
constitutional rules to begin with what
are they in American government stall
work of American government is our
balance of power the limitations that
are placed upon this balance of power it
is the role of the legislative to create
these rules under which we live it is
the role of the judicial to discern
disputes to resolve differences within
these rules the executive has a very
unique position because the executive is
allowed to act outside and above these
rules John Locke argues that there are
many things that which law cannot
provide for and these necessarily must
be left to the discernment of him who
wields executive power in his hands
without taking this to the extreme there
are limits that our founders placed on
what this discernment entails an
American government the executive has
specific enumerated powers they are
allowed to act with what political
theorists call energy they must be an
energetic executive they must be able to
act to enforce the laws which we have
established through a sense of urgency
and a sense of expediency they have this
discernment in a state of emergency when
we're in war or when there's a natural
disaster of some kind but it is that
state of emergency that has changed you
see through our initial balance of power
the presidency of the United States of
America the executive power does not
really limit the other powers very much
Barack Obama to date through his seven
years in offices only signed three
vetoes on every single bill that has
come across his desk yet before 1893
when Cleveland first left office there
was no single president whoever averaged
more than 28 executive orders per year
to date this has snowballed to a total
of thirteen thousand six hundred and
ninety-one total executive orders signed
by the President of the United States of
America because no president since that
time has ever signed fewer than 30 per
year Barack Obama January 21st 2015
signed an executive order under which he
declares the Arctic to be and I quote of
strategic cultural economic and
environmental importance to the United
States of America and quote with this
executive order what he does is he
establishes a committee to take care of
preserving the polar ice caps to take
care of exploring and protecting the
Arctic now if this is a state of
emergency today what have we lost we
have lost the guarded cautious
deliberate approach to the rules under
which we live that the legislature
initially sought out to attain instead
anything that is deemed necessary by the
executive is left to the discernment of
the executive
this leads to sweeping reforms in health
care education welfare reform
immigration the list goes on but because
this fundamental state of emergency has
been redefined we have changed the
limits of the executive power of the
United States of America because we have
allowed them to have discernment in
areas in which they previously had no
discernment now the sign of inductive
reasoning leads itself to very obvious
conclusions if Barack Obama can declare
a polar emergency to save penguins and
dr. Arnn can declare a fashion emergency
from I tie the reasoning extended
extends itself in American government
now that may be a frivolous example but
this really is a serious matter the
rules under which the rules are created
by which we treat one another have
fundamentally been altered because their
limits have been changed and the powers
have become imbalanced the executive
power is no longer something that act
urgently in a state of emergency because
they can declare to be a state of
emergency that which previously was
known was not considered to be expedient
circumstances exigent situations because
of this Buchanan argues that we live
under a different contract than that
under which we initially came together
as a political society now cynical
economists may talk a lot about
contracts in the contract of our
Constitution but at the end of the day
the Constitution is more than that
because it is the rules by which we
engage with one another and if we allow
the limits of those rules to change if
we allow one power to become so expanded
that they can define for themselves what
their level of discernment is in
creating those rules then we've lost the
purpose of those rules to begin with
Robinson Crusoe may have set up rules
for himself to order his own life as we
all do with personal habits
but when we come together we must be
very careful about how those rules are
created to begin with because they are
very susceptible to change and we must
not allow those limits to be expanded